il aurait des effets bénéfiques pour de
nombreuses conditions médicales on songe
même à l'utiliser dans le traitement de
certains cancers mais il n'est pas pour
tout le monde le jeûne intermittent
ne pas manger juni ça peut faire peur un
jeune arrêté de manger pour une certaine
période donc de façon générale tout le
monde jeunes la nuit c'est pour ça que
le matin où des jeunes ont déjà
effectivement le jeune ont toujours fait
partie des études ont toujours fait
partie même si on recule de plusieurs
décennies centaines d'années dans
différentes religions t en culture le
jeune homme toujours fait partie de
l'histoire
la nouvelle tant dans son rayon des
jeunes c'est le jeûne intermittent où
l'on ne mange que pendant une certaine
période de la journée c'est sûr que les
schémas de yoko tout en angleterre aux
etats unis c'est la hongrie mais la
tienne je me méfie toujours quand c'est
devenu à ce point et le populaire parce
que tu avoir des dérapages mais les
pistes de bronze qui sous tendent le
jeune est calme et à son sérieux je
rentre le jeûne intermittent dans l'air
le long dédié c'est une restriction
c'est une restriction calorique c'est le
restrictions logique pragmatique maths
et menacé
plusieurs expériences de mauvaises j'ai
joué beaucoup et yoyo
je voulais avoir quelque chose de plus
permanent de vitesse qu'une recette
miracle dominique a entrepris sa
nouvelle façon de s'alimenter sous la
supervision des lises la tour de
l'institut de cardiologie au pas de
jaune était mi temps on peut parler de
jeunes en jour alternant donc une
journée je mange normalement une journée
je vais je n'ai ont parfois le jeune
périodiques aux jeunes une ou deux
journées les cinq autres journées on
mange normalement
moi je vais aller plus vers
l'alimentation qu'on dit limitée dans le
temps où on consent notre alimentation
dans une fenêtre de temps bien précis de
cette façon de faire le don va permettre
de angers à tous les jours mais notre
fenêtre va être beaucoup plus petit je
dis non à 11 ans si le premier repas je
vais prendre puis je peux pas manger
plus tard que certains le 10 novembre
pour avoir mon césar de jeunes on attend
souvent le sai je vais donc ça veut dire
on est 16 heures sans manger on en
fenêtre de 8 heures pour manger dans ma
fenêtre de huit âgés au moins deux repas
par jour et là c'est possible d'avoir
tous les éléments nutritifs qu'on a
besoin les besoins et institutionnels
recommandé en mangeant de repos par jour
au début c'est difficile parce que deux
repas par jour où j'avoue que la fin au
début de ces un peu un sauvage jeté un
gros mangeur c'est normal c'est naturel
ou trois à quatre heures de ressentir la
faim fait quand on fait un jeu indique
en fait on vient se priver de nourriture
pendant certaines périodes sarrès
convient berry mais où venir contrer ce
qu'ils nous montrent naturellement de
notre camp c'est à dire d'avoir faim à
certains moments de la journée
si le corps peut bien vivre sans
nourriture solide pendant des heures
pour le liquide c'est autre chose
ma période où nos jeunes que ce soit
12h01 14 heures à 16 heures c'est très
important de bien s'hydrater donc de
boire de l'eau ou de boire de l'eau
régulièrement de l'eau gazéifiée je peux
boire du thé des tisanes je peux boire
du café avec un minimum de leeuw idéal
manoir
au départ le jeûne intermittent peut
traduire certains effets indésirables
les gens en plus grande difficulté à se
concentrer parfois à avoir de l'énergie
pour faire
partager ce quotidien moi je recommande
aux jeunes qui sont intéressés d'avoir
une discussion avec un des tortionnaires
justement pour s'assurer qu'au départ
tous les besoins nutritionnels sont
atteints on se lance pas dans le jaune
était mitaine de n'importe quelle façon
adoptée par des milliers d'influenceurs
sur les réseaux sociaux le jeûne est à
mi temps à des effets bien réelle sur la
santé
j'ai des gens qui ont aucun problème
connu qui prennent aucun muscle s'il
était impossible de joindre de façon
raisonnable on a au delà de l'appel du
poids parce qu'un homme pour toujours
mais l'appel du poids il ya une foule
d'améliorations métaboliques qui se
produisent assez rapidement un gros
intérêt pour les maladies
neurodégénératives a utilisé le jeune
parce que à ce moment là le serbe au
bénéficie de deux constats nick plutôt
que de ceux avec des effets très
positifs sur les neurones il est fait
pousser sur la commission et la
prévention des démences et les autres
maladies dégénératives
neurodégénératives comme le parking
diabète épilepsie cellules cancéreuses
est-ce que c'était démontré chez lui
mais
le sentier du contrôle
on les amène souvent vers le sentier de
la désinhibition et de la perte de
contrôle par la suite c'est ça qu'on
voit avec les diètes puis c'est le
risque on voit aussi aller avec les gens
21 ans prudence si vous avez des
conditions médicales particulières
je recommanderais pas déjà la pression
demain efficace que
les patients peuvent se retrouver avec
des chutes de pression artérielle ou d
hypoglycémie et que mange-t-on entre
deux jeunes des lieux mon père manger
autant qu'on veut puisse vraiment
diminué portion viandes diminuent des
portions de riz de sucre la capelle dans
les féculents et l'est
encore plus axé sur les plantes dont à
mi chemin le végétarisme et une
alimentation mais ce pyrénées lot vous
avez la meilleure combinaison
potins pour l'hypertension le diabète
l'obésité les maladies vasculaires et
ses limites et les animaux qui sont
vraiment une transe forme ils sont
souvent très riches en gras en ce qui à
16 pour parce que jon que c'est animal
devient de bon pour la santé ils nous
contactent
maintenant ça va très bien j'ai aucune
le cas j'arrive à midi les fois mais je
dépense on dire je pense pour punir
rendu dans l'après midi je fais que ça
va bien ça va très très bien les études
le monde ça dure quelques semaines
maximum quelques mois puis les gens
reviennent dans leurs habitudes mais pas
par manque de motivation parce que le
camp reprend ses droits tout simplement
d'idéaux encore hier j'en ai parlé à
deux anciens gerdi toujours sauce d'un
mode de vie que vous allez
comprendre aux moments là c'est
maintenant c'est pas façon de vous
alimentez poli
[Musique]